One problem left, problem
number 20.
There are 75 more
women than men
enrolled in Linden College.
If n men enrolled, then in terms
of n, what percentage of
those enrolled are men?
Well, they're saying that n is
men, so n is equal to number
of men, right?
They tell us that.
And there are 75 more women
than men, right?
So what is equal to the
number of women?
We know that there are 75 more
women than men, so it
must be n plus 75.
I think I'm coming down
with something.
And then they say well, in terms
of n, what percentage of
those enrolled are men?
So if we want to know the
fraction that are men, it's
the number of men over the
total number of students.
So the total number of students
is going to be the
men plus the women.
So the men is n plus the women
is n plus 75, right?
So this tells us the fraction
that are men.
So this is n over 2n plus 75.
This would be some decimal
number, and if I want to
convert this to a percentage,
I'd multiply it times 100 and
add a percent sign right here.
And if I wanted to rewrite that,
it would be 100n over 2n
plus 75 percent.
And that is choice e.
I have all this extra time I
don't know what to do with.
I guess I will let you use
it more productively then
watching me do nothing
on a video.
I'll see you in the
next SAT Section.